The track team was really just a big family.
Brothers and sisters and the coaches are your
parents, keeping you in line.
We would travel together, spend close to 40
hours a week together.
The track team was very large.
I think we had about 40 guys and the same
amount of women.
We'd travel to meets with 60 or 70 athletes.
We'd bring to a national meet, we brought
probably 15 guys and 15 girls.
Yeah, my relationship with Coach Lumberg was
really strong.
He recruited me to Hillsdale, but he's a distance
coach, cross country coach.
We have a field events coach who was going
to be my coach, it's Coach Teft.
He's really the one who was able to mold me
into the athlete that I became.
We spent a lot of time together, but there's
a lot of trust that has to happen.
I trust what they're doing.
Thank goodness Coach Teft had a lot of experience.
He would give me all the advice that I needed
to change my workouts or keep them the same
or change my steps.
It was a great working relationship, because
these guys are so easy to get to know, easy
to work with and they just love everyone they
work with, as long as you're willing to put
in the work and the time.
The success that I had as a collegiate athlete
was coupled with failures as well.
The failures that I had were mostly during
the season trying different things, but it
was an experiment that Coach Teft and I and
Coach Lundberg were working to figure out,
what was going to be the best to prepare me
for the big dance, which is the Nationals.
In my freshman year, I was fifth in the country
in the high-jump.
I have eight times as an All American, I feel
like I represent the teams of the early '90's.
We had a great string from '91, '92, '93,
'94.
We lost the first year of the GLIAC championship,
but we never lost after that.
I represent Coach Teft, Coach Lundberg, Coach
Martha, and I'm just the guy who gets to get
inducted for the Hall of Fame for them.
I just feel like I'm their representative.